this was the first visit to china by un
human rights commissioner in nearly two
decades
michelle bachelet was even presented
with a gift a book written by president
xi jinping with the title excerpts on
respecting and protecting human rights
china stands accused of brutal
repression against the uyghurs and other
minorities and this was the un's
official response
in the senior and we were autonomous
regions i have raised questions and
concerns about the application of
counterterrorism and deradicalization
measures underground application
particularly their impact on the right
of uighurs and other predominantly
muslim minorities one wonders what those
questions and concerns will do for these
people these files leaks earlier this
week show the faces of people detained
in xinjiang there are thousands of them
abdulrahman is from xinjiang and now
lives in turkey
he broke down crying when he looked
through those photos
he was hoping
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the chinese authorities do as much as
they can to prevent people seeing for
themselves the sky news has found
reporting there over recent years
a more comprehensive but long delayed
report on xinjiang is due to be
published by the un
uiga people are hoping for more than
just questions and concerns they need
answers
what has happened to their families tom
cheshire sky news beijing